venez vite on va voir chair de poule
anna un problème télé enfermé son père
d'un psychopathe est une copie
aux minables homme des neiges de
pasadena ce sont tous des manuscrits de
chair de poule mais pourquoi ces livres
sont verrouillées
tu as ouvert un livre je vais le
remettre à sa place maintient le flacon
tu te libérer tous les monstres que j'ai
créée
il faut absolument les expédier dans
l'avenir vous avez tous lu non si on
connaît leurs collègues
on peut les capturer on est les seuls à
pouvoir le faire
dans des granges
quoi qu on y est presque on oui
des nains de jardin peut-être qu'ils
sont gentils après tout ils sont pas
gentils ils sont pas du tout gentil